good afternoon everyone my name is Dr
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is SCP
6362 containment class ker disruption
class vlam and risk class
danger special containment procedures
Foundation WebCrawler iob BR KR is to
monitor search engines forums and
psychiatric records for any information
potentially relating to SCP
6362 if investigation of a flagged post
suggests a genuine SCP 63 62a instance
they are to be recovered immediately
recovered SCP 63 62a instances must be
under constant surveillance their
containment cells are to be fully
covered by cameras when not in their
containment cell an SCP 6362 a instance
must be accompanied by at least one
person at all times these containment
procedures are untested and speculative
as a living SCP 63 62a instance has
never been
recovered description SCP 6362 a
designates anyone affected by SCP 636 2
criteria for becoming an SCP 63 62a
instance if any exist are unknown during
an SCP 6362 event 3 to7 adult humans
designated 63 62b will appear near SCP
6362 a SCP 63 62b instances have been
recorded to appear behind or within any
object that can reasonably conceal them
I.E within locked rooms on balconies
under countertops within cupboards or
behind shower curtains SCP 63 62b
instances may also appear directly
behind SCP 6362 a though this is rare
SCP 63 62b instances are typically male
and are always fully clothed their
ethnicity physical build and overall
appearance vary they have never been
recorded to vocalize emote or attempt to
communicate in any way after appearing
all instances of SCP 6362 B will
Converge on SCP 6362 a and physically
assault them for an SCP 6362 event to
occur an SCP 6362 a instance must be
conscious and unseen by any other human
SCP 6362 events occur in intervals
lasting anywhere from 1 year to 2 weeks
no method of consistently triggering an
SCP 6362 event is currently
known an SCP 6362 event will end
immediately if any of the following
conditions are met SCP 6362 a loses
Consciousness SCP 6362 a dies another
human observes an instance of SCP 63
62b and all instances of SCP 6362 B are
terminated when an SCP 6362 event ends
any remaining SCP 63 62b instances
disappear leaving no physical trace of
their existence no blood clothing or
hair belonging to an instance of SCP 63
62b has ever been recovered however any
injury sustained by SCP 6362 a or Damage
Done to the environment will remain all
information on SCP 6362 has originated
from journal entries Forum posts
psychiatric evaluations and letters
these documents are rare as most SCP 63
62a instances are terminated during SCP
6362 events before recording anything
useful about the anomaly addendum
63621 1998
11:14 the following police report was
filed by Officer Larry Marx of the Los
Angeles Police
Department on 11:14 1998 at
approximately 2230 hour
I responded to a reported shooting at
Council Street and North Benton way upon
arriving at the house the occupant Jacob
Harris stepped outside and ran towards
me screaming for help his head was
bleeding and his left eye was swollen
Harris claimed that he had just been
attacked by several strangers he claimed
that he shot two before being disarmed
by them and running outside I summoned
an ambulance to the scene upon brief
investigation I found no bodies or
evidence of forced entry I did find
Harris's pistol on the floor near the
front entrance which I claimed as
evidence the ambulance arrived and
paramedics placed Harris inside there is
nothing further to
report after questioning Harris was
placed in the care of a psychiatric
hospital he expired 6 months later with
an unlocked bathroom cause of death was
listed as a crushed trachea in addition
to several other minor wounds no
evidence or susp ects were found
addendum
63622 2001
0211 the following is a handwritten
letter written by 32-year-old Daniel
Wallace it is addressed to his family
home no return address is
listed Lisa I'm sorry for leaving but I
couldn't handle it anymore I'm not crazy
not like you think I am it's real maybe
not to you or the kids but it is to me
people keep breaking in and hurting me I
know it sounds crazy you look at me like
I'm crazy Ben is scared of me my own kid
is scared of me but I didn't break my
arm or tear the bathroom door off its
hinges or give myself a concussion it's
been
them these people just show up I don't
know how they get in it's like they just
appear out of nowhere they just come out
of nowhere all always when I'm alone
this place isn't possible to find and if
they do God forbid I'm going to kill
them there's a gun in every room I carry
one with me all the time I won't let it
happen again this cabin isn't possible
to find when I see a stranger any
stranger I'll know what's happening I'll
kill
them I've got enough food to last for
years mirrors on every wall two locks
and a dead bolt on every door they're
never going to sneak up on me please
don't try to visit me I love you all I'm
going to drive into town and drop this
letter off and after that I'm not
leaving this cabin again I can't I love
you
Daniel two days after the letter was
written Wallace died when his vehicle
swerved off the road and collided with a
concrete barrier official cause of death
was head trauma however he was found
with back arm and neck injuries that
were inconsistent with a car accident
the letter was found in the passenger
seat deemed by law enforcement to be
accidental adendum
6362 3 2017
0415 the following is a handwritten
letter addressed to the Pentagon
building the author is
unknown I killed them all one broke a
window and slid inside like a cat the
other two kicked my front door off its
hinges I killed all three God made man
sure but Samuel Colt made them equal I
want you to know that the last one took
a long time to die shot him right in the
gut he just bled and stared at me there
wasn't anything behind those eyes
nothing human he didn't tell me anything
whatever training they get it's good but
mine is better and when he died they all
just puffed out of existence just like
the last few times
no bodies no blood can't wait for you to
try again
attempts to trace the sender
have failed investigations showed that
neither the Pentagon nor any branch of
the US government is connected to SCP
6362 addendum
20180329 the following is the only
recoverable entry from a journal
belonging to Robert Paisley
my neighbor he's been outside for too
long doesn't take that long to Mo Alan
doesn't take that long to Mo Al he just
keeps stopping and looking paranoid or
pretending to clear grass from the
blades he's just trying to look towards
my house he's casing it he's getting
ready to break in I know it the last few
times it's been him I know it's been him
he's pulling the strings telling them
when I'm alone and when my wife is away
they just break in and beat me they
don't say
anything this has happened five times
and nobody believes me but last
time was different they were beating me
and he interrupted it he just walked
into my house said he heard something
but that's the second he came
in they went away he made them go away
it was his up way of telling me
who's in
control the journal was recovered
following its submission as evidence in
the case of Marcus Anderson's murder
Anderson lived across the street from
Paisley and was found stabbed to death
in his home Paisley has yet to be
[Music]
found this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you are all dismissed
[Music]
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to
zargaran
BP o crop guy the
Morgan James Saba Irish
wwatch Lost Boy
segnar your local Foundation agent
zazaon worthy fire Dr Wolf
cubster Dean
Denis that loser casadia cams braded
Peach GM's Wright Rowan
O'Brien
kegn
grimnir extra moments
123 and Swift
raw if you would like a special thank
you at the end of each of my videos and
some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com slthe vulgan thank
[Music]
you